tenemos tres amigos guinea sara y bruno
que se han estado fijando en su peso a
lo largo del último mes y en particular
tenemos aquí anotados que tanto
cambiaron de peso en este mes y bueno
para obtener cuál es el cambio de peso
en ese mes lo que uno tiene que hacer es
tomar el valor de cuánto pesa uno
ahorita al final del mes aunque tenemos
cuánto pesan al final del mes final y le
restamos cuánto pesaban al inicio del
mes que inició y esto esta cantidad para
cada una de estas personas es cuánto
cambiaron de peso entonces tenemos el
cambio de peso de estas tres personas
aquí
gina tiene un cambio de peso de menos 3
kilos o sea que perdió 3 kilos
sara tiene un cambio de peso de 2.5
kilos así es que estará subió dos kilos
y medio y bruno subió cuatro kilos y ya
que tenemos esta información estaría muy
interesante preguntarnos estas tres
cosas quién perdió la mayor cantidad de
peso o quién tuvo el mayor cambio de
peso y quién tuvo el menor cambio de
peso entonces te recomiendo que le
pongas una pausa al vídeo y resuelvas
estas preguntas por tu cuenta
bueno ahora vamos a resolver juntos
estas preguntas por aquí tengo mi recta
numérica y pues vamos a poner cuál fue
el cambio de peso de nuestros amigos en
la recta numérica aunque empezamos con
jing jing a tuvo un cambio de peso de
menos tres kilos entonces del cero nos
vamos al menos 3
por aquí este fue el cambio de peso de
gym sarah ganó dos kilos y medio
entonces tuvo un cambio de peso
por aquí aunque aquí esté el cambio de
peso de sal y finalmente bruno ganó 4
kilos entonces el cambio de peso de
bruno está por aquí aunque bueno
entonces ahora sí vamos a contestar
estas preguntas quien perdió la mayor
cantidad de peso cuando nos estamos
preguntando quién perdió peso nos
estamos preguntando quién tuvo un cambio
de peso hacia la izquierda y aquí
queremos saber quién es el que se movió
más hacia la izquierda y bueno en
realidad china es la única que se movió
hacia la izquierda aunque porque sara y
bruno los dos ganaron peso aunque yo
entonces la que perdió más peso fue
llena
gina bueno ahora vamos con la siguiente
pregunta quien tuvo el mayor cambio
aquí lo que nos estamos preguntando es
quién cambio más de peso sin importar si
lo ganaron o lo perdieron y la forma más
fácil de ver eso es ver quién se alejó
más del cero y para saber eso lo más
fácil es ver quién tiene el valor
absoluto más grande el valor absoluto de
menos 3 es verbal bar absoluto de menos
3 aunque bueno mejor aquí vamos a hacer
una nueva columna
que se llame cambio absoluto cambio
absoluto o cambio absoluto de peso
entonces cuál es el valor absoluto de
menos 3 valor absoluto de menos 3
es simplemente 3 y ahora cuál es el
valor absoluto de 2.5 2.5 es 2.5 y el
valor absoluto de 4
es simplemente 4 entonces quien tuvo el
mayor cambio pues el mayor cambio lo
tuvo por uno que subió cuatro kilos en
segundo lugar tenemos a guinea que bajó
tres kilos porque aunque ella haya
bajado de peso de todas formas el cambio
absoluto de peso o sea el valor absoluto
de cuánto cambio de peso es tres kilos
que es más grande que lo que subió de
peso sara pero bueno el que más cambio
de peso fue bruno
bruno bueno y ahora quien es el que tuvo
el menor cambio de peso pues tenemos
aquí a sara que tuvo un cambio absoluto
de peso de 2.5 sara es la que menos
cambio de peso la que menos se alejó del
cero
es cierto que gina bajó de peso y que
sara subió de peso pero en cuanto a
quien cambio menos quien se alejó menos
del cero sara tuvo un menor cambio aquí
el valor absoluto del cambio o sea el
cambio absoluto de sara es más chico que
el de jean auel de bruno aunque hay aquí
tenemos el cambio absoluto de sara que
es 2.5 que es más chico que el cambio
absoluto de gene que es 3 o el de bruno
que es 4
entonces la que tuvo el menor cambio fue
sara